Episode 3 of The Falcon and the Winter Soldier,
"Power Broker," was a fight-filled good time,
packed with plot and globetrotting galore.
It also had its share of Easter eggs. Here
are a few you may have missed.
In "Power Broker," we finally get to see Helmut
Zemo, whose return has been looming since
the series began. Knowing that the villain
is the only way to help track down the origin
of the new Super-Soldier serum, Bucky helps
him break out of a high-security prison with
ease. After getting the kinda-sorta approval
from Sam, the three men are treated to a private
plane ride across the globe.
It turns out that Zemo is rich — really
rich — and there's a reason why. Finally,
we hear this classic Marvel villain note that
he is a baron, a title that's long been associated
with Zemo in the comics, but never yet uttered
in the MCU, until now. Zemo was a member of
the Sokovian aristocracy, but that was all
taken from him when Ultron decimated the country.
In the comics, the Zemos are actually of German
descent. There have been 13 barons in total,
with Helmut being the most recent. In 1973's
Captain America #168, we learn that Helmut
and his father were both disfigured by Adhesive
X, the most powerful adhesive ever invented,
and thus later donned masks to hide their
faces. There's no instance of Adhesive X or
any kind of disfigurement of Zemo in the MCU,
so his mask-wearing is likely just an homage
to the character and his father.
Most Marvel Comics fans are well aware of
Madripoor, a fictional Southeast Asian island.
While a lot of exciting stories have gone
down here, Madripoor is most closely associated
with something we've yet to see in the MCU:
mutants. Namely, Wolverine.
Madripoor is first mentioned in 1985's New
Mutants #32. Wolverine spends a decent amount
of time here, going by the name of Patch.
Even beyond Wolverine, though, the X-Men's
connections to Madripoor are endless. We learn
that Mystique wanted to set up an X-Men haven
there in 2015's All-New X-Men #37. Magneto
uses the island as a temporary holding zone
for time-displaced mutants in 2017's X-Men
Blue #1. With Madripoor now canon in the MCU,
we can expect several visits to the island
moving forward — possibly led by mutant
characters.
"Power Broker" also contains subtle nods to
Madripoor's Lowtown, including brief shots
of local businesses made famous in the comics.
The Princess Bar and the Brass Monkey (also
known as the Bronze Monkey), where Sam, Zemo,
and Bucky meet Selby, are iconic Lowtown hotspots.
In the comics, the Princess Bar is owned by
a man named O'Donnell, and offers entertainment
to residents of both Hightown and Lowtown.
But O'Donnell doesn't run the show on his
own: He has help from his silent partner,
Wolverine. Given Wolverine's stature in Marvel
canon, this is an homage that shouldn't be
taken lightly.
The Falcon and the Winter Soldier has done
a fabulous job so far referencing fan-favorite
scenes from prior MCU projects. In "Power
Broker," we get a playful throwback to a scene
from Captain America: Civil War, in which
Sam refuses to move his seat up for Bucky
while they wait for Steve to talk to Sharon
Carter.
"Can you move your seat up?"
"No."
After Sam and Bucky meet Doctor Nagel in the
shipping containers and all hell breaks loose,
they jump into a swanky convertible which
Zemo has been hiding. Sam takes the back seat,
which offers little leg room, and a callback
to the beloved moment follows.
“You're not gonna move your seat up, are
you?"
"No."
Just before diving into Lowtown, Sam is given
a very brief history of the man he is supposed
to be impersonating: Conrad Mack, AKA the
Smiling Tiger. Luckily, Sam resembles Conrad,
whom he notes has a "bad nickname." First
appearing in 1992's New Warriors #19, Conrad
is the son of a Vietnam veteran and a cult
member who deals in magic.
Conrad is also affiliated with the Thunderbolts,
a team of reformed criminals led by Helmut
Zemo himself. Smiling Tiger doesn't have an
extensive history in the comics, and we likely
won't see much more of him moving forward
in the MCU.
But his mention does open the door for the
Thunderbolts, also occasionally known as the
Masters of Evil, who have a long and fascinating
history. The group has further ties to the
Winter Soldier and Black Widow, who have both
led the team during different moments in its
history.
In "Power Broker's" final moments, we get
a shocking cameo from Ayo, a member of the
Wakandan Dora Milaje. We first meet Ayo in
Captain America: Civil War, when she tells
Natasha Romanoff to move so T'Challa can enter
his car. If Natasha refuses to comply, Ayo
makes it clear that she "will be moved" by
force. She reappears in Black Panther and
Avengers: Infinity War, serving under General
Okoye.
Ayo is here for one purpose, and one purpose
only: To collect Zemo, the man responsible
for the death of King T'Chaka. Many unanswered
questions linger: Namely, how the meeting
between Bucky and Ayo came to be, and how
the latter knows Zemo is out of prison and
ready for the taking. Nevertheless, Ayo's
appearance officially ties Wakanda into the
events of The Falcon and the Winter Soldier.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier are coming soon. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one.